[upbeat pizzicato music]
Aharoni: My name is Tomer.
I'm a computer science student.
I like to see
people enjoy the things I make.
One day, I got a voice note.
I wanted to listen to it instantly,
but I didn't want to play it
in the middle of the class.
So, using Google Docs,
I was able to dictate
that voice note into text.
Then I started thinking,
can I do something bigger than that?
And I was like,
"Hey, Alon, what's up?
"Do you want to maybe create phone calls
for people who are deaf
or hard of hearing?"
Ezer: The common way to communicate
with someone who is deaf
or hard of hearing
is using a relay service.
You can't use the phone
without someone listening to you.
Aharoni: And we wanted to fix that.
Ezer: The hardest part
was not the technology
but understanding,
how are we gonna build it?
When we encountered Google Cloud,
it changed everything for us.
They had the text-to-speech APIs
that we needed.
They had hosting services
and everything under one roof.
Aharoni: I think in less than 12 hours,
we were able to create a proof of concept.
The moment we saw Nagish working
was the moment
I felt like an actual software engineer,
because I created something.
We tested it ourselves,
but we didn't get to actually test it
with real users.
Today, we hope to do that
for the first time.
[uplifting music]
Taliah: Hi.
Aharoni: How are you today?
Taliah: I'm good.
Aharoni: Yeah?
Taliah: My name is Taliah.
I'm 18 years old,
and I'm from New York City.
I am hard of hearing.
So I read lips
in order to understand better.
When, like, I speak to someone
that doesn't know
that I have hearing loss,
they sometime, like, mock me as a joke.
It makes me, like,
just feel bad about myself.
Aharoni: Do you use phone calls?
Do you have smartphone?
What do you do today?
Taliah: No, I don't use the phone.
I just decline it if I understand
what they're trying to say,
and then I text them,
"Oh, what do you say?"
Aharoni: Yeah.
Taliah: "I didn't hear you."
Aharoni: We want to solve that.
Taliah: Okay.
The first person that I would call
is my mom.
My mom's my role model.
Aharoni: Maybe you could call her
and see how it works.
[phone line ringing]
automated voice: This is
an accessible phone call.
[phone beeps]
You are now connected.
Janet: Hi, Taliah.
What are you doing?
Taliah: Oh, wow.
[laughter]
Janet: Hey, are you going to go out
with your friends today?
automated voice: Yes, I am.
[laughter]
Janet: To see her smiling makes me smile.
I think this is a wonderful thing for--
for, you know, kids that are struggling.
This would be, like,
a different world to them.
Aharoni: Yeah.
It makes me super happy.
Like, how was it for you
to place a phone call like that?
Taliah: Honestly, it makes me feel like
I can do the stuff
that normal people can do.
It's amazing feeling.
Yeah.
[uplifting music]